Roy at the present time our senses are
inadequate to do the things you
mentioned however with the addition of
technology it is very easy to imagine a
time in the future when we would have
super senses for example our eyeball can
only see red green and blue the primary
colors but animals can see different
colors bees for example can see
ultraviolet radiation that's how they
lock on to the Sun when it's raining and
it's cloudy you think that bees would
starve to death because they don't know
where the flower patch is wrong they
lock onto the Sun and in under
ultraviolet radiation bees can see the
Sun so for us however we can't see
infrared we can't see ultraviolet
however it is possible that one day
we'll have contact lenses contact lenses
with full internet capability so we will
blink and we will be online and these
contact lenses could be sensitive to
infrared or ultraviolet radiation in
which case we could see radiation that
is invisible to us already it's possible
to get the x-ray vision of Superman if
you think of Superman comics you think
no way you can't have x-ray vision you
have half a photographic film behind the
person you would have to shine
photograph of shine x-rays develop the
film to get the x-ray of the person you
can't do that with an eyeball it turns
out we can there's something called
backscattered x-rays which gives you
x-ray vision a la Superman almost
indistinguishable from the x-ray vision
of Superman comics here's how you do it
you get a light bulb that emits x-ray
radiation that floods the room the
x-rays bounce off the walls then you put
on special goggles or lenses which are
sensitive to x-rays x-rays hit the wall
go behind the person's back go through
the person and into your goggles that's
how you do it without photographic film
it's called back scattered x-rays it
already exists and in fact because of
the 9/11 attack there's been a rush a
rush to put back scattered x-rays in
airports at the present time
in fact it's already
causing Civil Liberties lawsuits because
some people don't want their privacy
invaded they don't want a Superman to
look at them with their x-ray vision so
and even telepathy we have certain forms
of telepathy even today by putting MRI
scans and EEG scans onto our brainwaves
so we can actually peer now into the
fabric of our own thoughts
it's rather primitive however we have a
dictionary a dictionary of objects like
dogs cats houses and brain patterns so
by looking at a person's brain pattern
through an MRI you can actually tell if
the person is looking at a dog or a cat
that exists today in the future our
vocabulary of maybe 20 pictures may be
increased to a few thousand and at that
point that's beginning to look like real
telepathy